because I've been yeah I was I was going
to ask him of the more common Muslim
objections not just not because I don't
know the answers but because I want to
equip the audience who maybe hasn't been
exposed kind of the Normie Catholic if
you will so one of the common objections
against Christianity is just starting
with the beginning Christ never claimed
to be God answered that objection yeah
this is one someone asked me yeah Habib
Raj learned from Ahmed Caleb said yeah
Ahmed was the granddaddy of apologist in
the 90s ' 80s and 90s they all learned
from him yes now the
typical objection that everyone's going
to hear he's not exaggerating one of the
first questions you'll be asked is show
me where Jesus says I am God or worship
me in those exact words exactly and
they'll even say if you show show me
where Jesus said I am God or worship me
those exact words I'll get baptized this
Sunday you know because they know if you
read the gospels Jesus never comes out
and says I am God MH and those exact
words so they think they got you now how
do I respond to that well I respond to
it several ways first I say all right
let's see how consistent you are now I
want to hold you to your consistency I
can't show you where Jesus says I'm God
in those exact words but there's a
reason but before I get to the reason I
will take Shahar and I'll become a
Muslim if you show me in the Quran where
ASA Jesus saysi the Messiah and those
exact words he doesn't say it I will
become Muslim and take Shahar where you
show me where Jesus says I am the word
of Allah cast down to Mary doesn't say
that now for those of you who don't know
there's a verse in the
Quran chapter 4 verse 171 where Jesus is
said to be the word of Allah cast down
to Mary it says it the word of
him sent down to Mary that's John's
logos christology in a
nutshell that's John's christology
but it's mixed in with a lot of false in
fact
interestingly John of Damascus actually
thought that Muhammad was an Aryan in
his writings John of Damascus says that
Islam is an Aryan sect an Aryan heresy
it was it was at first believed to be
right yes John of Damascus and that
makes sense of these statements because
you have Jesus being the word who exists
and he comes down into Mary and a spirit
from him so then I say all right show me
where the Quran Jesus says I'm the word
of Allah I'm the spirit from him I'm the
virgin's born son of Mary if you can't
show me that then Islam is false so then
what they say well he doesn't have to
say it Allah says it I go
Bingo by the same principle I don't need
to show you Jesus saying I am God in
those words because in the scriptures we
have God the Father glorifying Christ as
God and as the Creator Hebrews 1 18 to12
so are you not going to accept that so
then that's one way but now for those
who want to know why Jesus didn't simply
come out and say I'm god well number one
that's an argument from Silence to begin
with the gospels do not record
everything Jesus said or did John
himself says that right John 20:30 and
John
21:25 so in theory he may have said to
his disciples I am God it's not recorded
but we won't even need to go there Jesus
is the perfect Communicator because he's
God's wisdom incarnate the infinite
uncreated wisdom of God the Son of God
the word of God God in essence and knows
his audience and he knows how to
communicate them in the perfect manner
for a first century
Jew when you come out and say I am God
without qualification that creates
confusion it doesn't bring Clarity why
because to a Jew the word god meant the
Father in heaven so if you were to say I
am God without qualification then they
would think that you're claiming to be
the father in Heaven and Jesus is not
the father in Heaven to prove that point
don't take my words for it to prove that
point when you say to Joe witness Jesus
Is God their program God is the father
Joe is the father so what they heard you
say is Jesus is the
father so when I say to Joe witness
Jesus Is God wait how can he be God was
he praying to himself did he send
himself is he his own son because in
their mind God means father similarly to
a first century Jewish context God would
have meant the father so how does Christ
communicate to them
I am God without confusing them into
thinking he's making himself out to be
the father the exact way he does it in
the gospels that's why they get it they
say you a man make yourself out to be
God see they get it I and the father are
one in context that I give eternal life
and no one plucks out on my hand no one
oh you're not the father we get it
because you're saying you and the father
are one but you just set things that
only God can say so now we get it you're
not the father and you're a man but you
still make yourself out to be God
blasphemy so there was no better way to
communicate his deity than the way he
did yeah only God can forgive sins your
sins are forgiven oh you don't believe
me pick up your mat and walk yeah and
even there notice he says that so you
may know the son of man has Authority
why because if they know Daniel they
know the son of man is different from
the ancient of
days so he's still making sure they
don't confuse him with the father
because anyone reading Daniel 7 who know
there are two figures the Ancient of
Days and the son of man so when he says
that you may know the son of man okay so
he's not the Ancient of Days but he's
the son of man but that son of man is
not a creature he's also Divine two
powers in
heaven yeah
see you know no that's that's a great
answer um before we get to some of the
viewers question I have one more
question that I think will be YouTube
friendly this one will be this one will
be safe I think so it's kind of a
two-part question Muslim comes to you
and he says the Bible is corrupt second
part of the question and the Quran is
perfect down to the last
Letter's you're throwing me what they
call like uh softballs is like but these
are common that's
why uh
well before I give you the answer I have
to remind folks you have to take your
audience into consideration and then
meet them where they're at this is 1
Corinthians 919- 23 for those of you
want to see a Biblical basis for this 1
Corinthians 9:1 19-23 Paul talks about
to the Jew I became a Jew to the one
under the law I became one under the law
to the one without law meaning he became
all things to everyone that he might win
some to Christ what does he mean he
means that he understood the thinking of
his audience he also understood the dos
and don't don'ts and then he tailored
his message that would make sense to his
audience so the way Paul would preach to
the Jews wasn't the same way he preached
to the Athenians he preached the same
truth but he made sure he preached in a
way that his audiences would get it why
do I say that when I'm dealing with a
Muslim the kind of argument I use for
Bible presentation is not the kind of
argument I use for Bart man yeah so for
example the Muslim believes the Quran is
God's word that's his final Authority so
like Paul who quoted the Greek pagans he
does it acts 17:28 he quotes two Greek
pagans both of whom are praising Zeus
but he takes what is said of Zeus and he
applies it to God the the father so here
it shows you Paul's sophistication he
knows the literature of the people he
knows the sources of the people he's
evangelizing and he knows what
statements to use to confirm the truth
of the Christian faith acts 17228 anyone
there go read it acts 1728 he goes as
one of
your own poets have said right that's
Titus 11:12 and acts 1728 we live and
move and have our being in him right so
he's quoting Pagan sources to pagans
because those statements are true and
all truth is God's truth so he's going
to take that truth that Satan stole and
christianize it and bring it back to
Christ that's what I do with the Quran I
say hold on since you believe the Quran
is God's word you must believe what the
Quran says about the Bible if the
Bible's corrupt the Quran is corrupt
Muhammad is an antichrist why because
the Quran and we've debated this it's
called the Islamic Dilma in fact I
debated a Harvard graduate PhD graduate
from
Harvard andani on the Islamic dilemma it
was on capturing Christianity's Channel
and I don't want to boast but it didn't
bwell for him yeah and everyone was
saying wow an internet apologist schools
in Harvard PhD you better get your money
back the Quran says that one of the
arguments for the veracity of Muhammad
this is one of the arguments Quran says
that hey you should believe mamm is a
prophet why because he confirms the
scripture
that you have there is verse after verse
after verse the Quran where Muhammad is
saying to the Jews and Christians of his
time you should believe in this Quran
because it confirms what's with you it
confirms what you have it verifies that
what you have is true so why don't you
believe in me because that's the problem
you just said what we have is true and
then we look at your Quran and it
contradicts what we have therefore
you're you're a liar but if then they
come back and tell me the Bible's
corrupt that means you know more than
the Quran because the Quran says it's
not corrupt so either Muhammad didn't
know what he's talking about or you
don't know what you're talking about but
either way you can't say Muslim so
that's how I silence that objection
because I don't care how many
manuscripts you point to that there's
over 25,000 manuscripts nearly 10,000
Latin of the books of the Bible and they
are basically substantially identical
and the variations do not affect it one
ear out the other they're not going to
listen so I bring Muhammad now as far as
the preservation of the Quran is
concerned that too is baloney anyone
reading the Islamic sources admit there
were variant Arabic qurans at the time
of Muhammad's companions not centuries
later when Muhammad died this is why I'm
going to guys I'm going to give you a
succinct version of this because we can
spend hours and weeks and if you ever
want me to come back and do a session we
can do that but the Muslim sources
deemed authentic by the sunnis state
clearly that when Muhammad died his
companions were writing down the Quran
that they learned directory from him and
they were contradictory and in Conflict
to the point that the Muslims almost
came to blows because they're accusing
one another of corrupting the Quran
that's how bad the were and they had
different like various qurans had
different amounts of chapters different
amounts of well I'm gonna mention that
since you brought it up Abdullah IB M if
you read the again guys I'm sorry some
of you may not know this but go to the
channel and type up Quran preservation
you'll get all the details Muhammad is
reporting to have said learn the Quran
from four men two of the men that he
mentioned by name two Abdullah remember
that name Abdullah Bin masud he goes
when you want to learn the Quran go to
him and another one was obai Bin k b can
you say that five times fast UB B cop so
you can't say I want to see Anthony
try with the accent Come on Anthony with
the ACC you and me are twins bro we were
separated at at Birth say say it one
more time uh UB B kab UB bin kab I'm not
saying you are my
brother sound like me too even though
I'm better looking but UB these two now
I'm just gonna focus on these two
Muhammad said learn the Quran from four
one is Abdullah and now they learned the
Quran directly from Muhammad when they
want to write down the Quran they could
not agree as to the number of verses of
each chapter or how many chapters abdah
only had 111 chapters the Quran today
has 114 chapters exactly bin kab had 116
chapters so now which is it did Muhammad
claim that Allah sent
down1 chapter suras is it 114 or 116
they couldn't agree yes not only that
but even the chapters themselves were at
variance so that the people that learned
the
from were reciting verses that the group
that learned from
Abdullah had never heard and vice versa
so they said hey you've been corrupting
the crown and they almost killed each
other yeah and
didn't bride she said that like uh that
a goat came in and ate one of the sheets
of the Quan that had this one is
hilarious this
isn't breastfeeding and stoning how dare
you this is G-rated Mister no but what
he's talking about Aisha mentions that
there was a sheet and that sheet it
contained the stoning verse because
according to the Sunni sources
Allah sent down the verse of stoning
adulterers but it's not found in the
present Quran so if you asked the Muslim
where is the command to Stone adulterers
in the Quran it's not there but their
own sources say it was part of the book
that it was part of the book it should
be there but it
disappeared not I'm sorry
who's the second Cale
said by Allah the stoning verse was part
of the book The Prophet stoned and we
stoned after him and then he says had it
not been for people accusing Omar of
tampering with the book of Allah I would
have added it to the book so look what
he's admitting it should be part of the
book it's not in the book but I'm afraid
if I add it they're going to accuse me
of corrupting the Quan now the story
with Aisha it's in MA number 19 44 my
memory doesn't Fail Me by the power of
the holy spirit in Jesus name she says
the sheet that had the verce of stoning
and what's called suckling now Anthony
you may have to go to confession after
this so I want you to be
ready there is a practice in
Islam where through breastfeeding we
become related so if my mother breastfed
me as a child and breastfed you you're
now my foster brother that so much
guys why is this inside joke or you just
pulling my leg Mister no he say maybe my
mother how
you yeah hey you're right my mom did
tell me that she used to breastfeed some
some neighbors kid disappeared they said
they were heading towards Canada there
you go brother love you man but the
breastfeeding turned out to be an
embarrassment look how bad it got
Muhammad the genius decided to abolish
adoption you cannot adopt in Islam why
because Muhammad married the divorced
wife of his adopted son exactly so
people started attacking him how dare
you take your son's wife but then Allah
said hey they're not really your sons
don't call them your sons no more
adoption now that's put Muhammad in a
dilemma because there were people who
had adopted children one in particular
had adopted a son he's now grown man now
he's no longer his adopted son now in
Islam you cannot remain in the house
where there a woman if you're not
related to them and so that sexual
intimacy is forbidden so if you are my
friend and I have sisters you can't come
to my house they have to be put in a
separate room and you definitely cannot
live in the house so now the the guy
he's now troubled well this dude here
he's a grown man he's not my son that
means there's nothing stopping him from
lusting for my wife so he got
uncomfortable so his wife goes to
Muhammad this is the she I won't believe
her too long but I want you to see how
silly and irrational and immoral this
religion is the real Miracle is that
people think Islam is a miracle so the
wife goes to Muhammad she goes look you
know my husband's uncomfortable he's a
grown man you know this guy that we
adopted and he's no longer adop what
should I do you know what Muhammad said
breastfeed
him yeah I'm not lying so he's like he
said breastfeed this is sah Muslim what
do you mean breastfeed him he goes he's
got a beard he's gr man he goes I know
breastfeed him so Muhammad taught if you
let a man suck your teeth 10 times he's
now your Foster son so can you imagine
what a what a bizarre
culture can you imagine the man is not
her son and somehow sucking her nipple
is gonna cure him of lust for the woman
it's like the thing he prescribes the
thing that's going to drive him to
lust you're uneducated clearly see now
initially it was 10 suckling but he
reduced it to five so merciful of him
very much so less Temptation so Aisha
said the sheet of the Quran that
contained the verse of stoning and
suckling was under my bed but we were
too busy bearing Muhammad and then and a
goat came and ate that sheep and the
verses are gone wow oh I wonder why I
wonder why well that's where the dog ate
my homework ho exactly